ver o ator diz pessoal aqui quem fala é
o lugar que sejam muito bem vindos é
mais um vídeo e eu gostava que é isso
que estamos terceiro episódio da cni
entre nós ainda não conseguimos enganar
regeane internet em que surge a calma
que neto tem carro mas ela está
tranquila tranqüilo tabu favorável está
tranquilo está favorável está tranqüilo
tavora o pai público depois de calculado
tá tranquilo estava voando tap
bom pessoal como sempre vou ver as
vossas sugestões nos comentários
primeira sugestão é débil em rick e ela
desde os quinto tento encontrar maria
sangrenta de sangrenta para quem não
sabe é que um mito urbano da mulher que
parece um espelho vocês disserem três
vezes para isso enfrenta um espaço
dentro de uma casa de banho a menina e
ela vai aparecer atrás vocês vai
disputar uma faca nas costas que vocês
morrem logo na hora o seu personagem faz
vídeos sobre a região o seu personagem é
real e supostamente uma lenda na polícia
não existe eu vou dizer que não o seu
personagem tem poder sim tem um poder de
ataque nas costas seu personagem faz
parte de um anime animação japonesa é um
bosque e lado estados unidos ela fala
inglês né
vocês têm uma versão que ela de merda e
eu nunca vi uma versão japonesa é não
existisse o personagem é dubai não é um
demônio que o tirasse daqui seu
personagem do jogo online kraft não é o
seu estágio já esteve no espaço não seu
personagem é de um jogo não bem não o
seu personagem é do gênero feminino sim
imagine o que era ver uma versão
masculina da marinha sangrenta este
marte porque o mário sangrento com maria
o sangrento joão sangue não o seu
personagem de um filme da disney não o
seu personagem faz parte de esportes não
ela está dentro dos padrões chave a lei
o seu estágio é um feiticeiro não o seu
personagem faz parte um filme de terror
eu acho que sim eu acho que há filmes
baseados nelas por seu personagem é um
brinquedo não o seu personagem já fez
sucesso na internet não o seu personagem
vai à escola também na única coisa que
ela tem que saber fazer essa faca nas
costas só o seu personagem faz parte de
uma série de tv também no domingo eu já
falei pergunta 18 e não está a conseguir
ganhar eu acho que é esta que nós vamos
conseguir enganar o seu personagem caiu
em um buraco e ela que está a tentar
adivinhar a samara essa marca criou para
dentro de um poço o seu personagem é
mais velho do que você
eu acho que sim né
não foi um demônio as mães porto velho
eu vou dizer que sim
o seu estágio tem apelo claro sim ela
está morto ela tem papel branco o seu
personagem é culpa do seu personagem é
acompanhado de uma criança não anotou
sozinho chava nos pele o seu personagem
é o personagem principal é um filme
existe um filme quebra de mary mas não
sei se é considerado o papel principal
eu vou dizer que não sai é o seu
personagem é uma flor também não o seu
personagem faz parte de sandimen para o
que é isso o homem de gerais não sabe o
que é ser mãe eu vou dizer que não você
encontra se o personagem segredos
importantes quanto a seu irmão o gol e
um jato ficar maluco está que nem mesmo
a próxima sugestão e tenta achar jesus
no maquineta kaká eu tenho quase certeza
que vai conseguir encontrar jesus porque
é uma personagem fácil mas vamos lá
tentar na mesma jato produto o seu
personagem é um desenho não o simples
passagem é português é português
eu acho que eu falava lá tinha uma coisa
assim possível e isso é considerado
português não eu não sair vou dizer que
não sai o seu personagem mora no seu
país eu moro em todo o lado é jesus o
seu personagem famoso sem fim é o seu
personagem é brasileiro não sai o seu
personagem tem bigode vamos ver jesus
tem bigode e barba sentem melhor o seu
personagem é um gênio eu vou dizer que
sim porque ouvi dizer que jesus
transformou água e pão ou vinho em água
eu acho que é bom em mim eu não sair vou
dizer que sim o seu estágio já foi
expulso da bgs
imagine o que era jesus girava e gs tem
uma boa e fãs o seu personagem tem
poderes curativos em loucura as pessoas
porque ela é jesus em postagens vive uma
história de moura sim porque jesus e
elano as pessoas todas seu personagem
faz parte de percy jackson não sei quem
vou dizer que não o seu personagem já
morreu na vida real sim
seu personagem é rapper e que é humano
eu sou jesus pontuam cheias bem
ficheiros de pets true só o personagem
nasceu na argentina não se o personagem
faz parte mais lenta o pão nba não se o
personagem já foi reduzido sem muitas
vezes
streck mal o que eu encontro com jesus
cristo como é que é possível mas ele não
dá não dá pra enganar não dá vamos lá
ver o que é que vocês plantaram mais por
favor comentem alguma coisa difícil por
favor tanto da sharia troca tem mesmo é
que nossa cota de 100 euros me muitos
comentários sempre a mesma coisa
encontra a placa de 100 mil do ângulo
que vocês não vão primeiro para quem não
sabe usar um anel no youtube que base
que me pediu pra ter o mesmo fez um
corte na placa de 100 mil inscritos que
o subiu 2 em outubro e esse filho ficou
viral é tipo de serviço e mais odiada
internet mas vocês querem checar a placa
e eu vou encontrá la a sério se eu
conseguir encontrando eu vou lhe aponta
e mato o seu personagem é português não
o seu personagem é um homem adulto a
placa é feita de ferro sós usuário
médico mas não é um homem o seu
personagem é uma mulher bonita eu acho
que sua mulher bonita oa não acreditava
mas nunca sabe o seu personagem tem
cabelo também não o seu personagem é do
bem eu vou dizer que sim porque
supostamente a placa é um prêmio que o
tubo ba e isso é uma coisa boa o seu
personagem é um lixo também não o seu
personagem é feito de metal não povo vai
encontrar a placa do seu personagem
principal em guerra das estrelas não o
seu personagem tem pernas não o seu
personagem tem dois olhos não o seu
personagem está ligado a comida também
não o seu personagem é um filho de um
personagem do ego
supostamente nós temos que encontrar um
personagem ea placa é um objeto por isso
eu acho que isso não conta com 16
pessoas para que elas tenham estoque já
sabem quanto você que favoritos quiserem
que esta série continuou deixe nos
comentários sugestões do personagem
difícil já não esquece é estamos no
próximo vídeo que mãe e até a próxima